[Musique]
à
ça fait vraiment plaisir d'être là avec
vous ce soir une journée une soirée
je n'oublierai probablement jamais de
tout je vous reconnais bien là sans
problème voilà partager cette place
aujourd'hui avec ces personnes qui m'ont
précédé pour moi est particulièrement
saisissant
parce que vous le découvrirez pourquoi
aujourd'hui je vais partager avec vous
ce que j'ai vécu dans ma vie personnelle
et j'espère que chacun d'entre nous en
tirer quelque chose en 1981 t1
une femme africaine une entrepreneure
courageuse bat anti-travailleurs
s'apprêtait à les faire le tour des
saisons entreprise l'entreprise donc des
commerces
elles étaient présents sainte cinq mois
de grossesse prête la partie dans sa vw
box vague la petite coccinelle pour ceux
qui connaissent qui connaît la
coccinelle
voilà donc à l'époque c'était une
voiture de luxe
ok elle pris sa voiture et s'est dirigé
vers ces entreprises pour faire le
check-in pour voir un peu ce qui se
passait ne sachant pas que ce jour là
serait le jour qui changerait sa vie
pour toujours
à l'arrivée au coin de la rue elle
rencontra un gros camion qui l'a pas
crue tard
écrasant sa voiture complètement elle à
l'intérieur avait brisé plusieurs aussi
en taille et de partout saigner comme
rien au monde
cette femme c'est la mer
envoyé à l'hôpital il fallait faire un
avortement cinq mois de grossesse on
pouvait pas faire grand chose
c'est le moment le plus obscur de sa vie
et à côté d'eux il y avait mon père mais
cassard qui n'avait pas cessé d'être la
personne qu'il fallait auprès d'elle
malgré tout ce que le monde pouvait dire
vous savez beaucoup attentes que vous
tombiez pour se lever et beaucoup
voulaient que moi qu'à ça arrête d'être
l'infirmier de cette femme qui
apparemment était insolente par son
orgueil par sa réussite
à l'époque il était resté à ses côtés
contre vents et marées ma mère était
déclarée affirme handicapées
elle ne pouvait plus concevoir ne
pouvait plus avoir d'enfant s'est défini
pour elle plus jamais d'enfant
le docteur disait et mon père dit écoute
docteur je ne suis pas en train de
chercher des enfants vous savez j'en ai
déjà 7
c'est l'afrique c'est l'été aucun
problème au départ mais vous savez en
afrique en tant qu'entrepreneur pour
avancer quelques fois il faut donner des
crédits à ses voisins à ses clients
espérant qu'il vous plaît à la fin du
mois c'était le cas pour ma mère mais à
sa sortie de l'hôpital elle était
obligée d'aller justement cherché à
avoir l'argent qu'on lui devait
mais en ce moment là c'était plus la
femme forte qu'elle était c'était plus
la femme imposante
ce n'était plus la femme que tout le
monde craignait
c'était ce qu'on appelait une handicapée
arrivé chez une personne précisément
maman dis bonjour comment allez vous je
suis là pour mon argent est ce que je
pourrais l'avoir adam dît et maman tu
viens chez moi le matin comme ça c'est
la sorcellerie ou quoi
s'il vous plaît il faut pas déranger les
gens comme ça tu sais pas comment j'ai
passé ma vie
on l'a dit mais quand tu venais chercher
mon histoire tu m'as pas tu n'as pas du
tout cette philosophie qu'est ce qui se
passe à marly 10 de tous de façon tu
n'es qu'une page tu peux pas avoir
d'enfant voilà pourquoi tu es jaloux
parce que nous pouvons toujours avoir
des enfants
et toi tu ne peux pas vraiment été
brisées comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
elle voulait simplement son argent des
choses qu'elle avait donnée à crédit
une épave incapable de produire
il égale aux autres femmes à quoi
pouvait bien t elle servir à gérer la
purée et mon père et c'est le bla
consoler comme d'habitude maman pleurer
elle été détruites
moi une épave aujourd'hui une fable
comme moi une femme indépendante
on m'appelle et parle parce que j'ai
besoin de mon argent à prier elle
voulait un autre enfant elle était
décidée elle voulait prouver au monde
qu'elle n'était pas une et par quelques
années plus tard elle découvrit qu'elle
était enceinte il dit à mon père m'a
cassé
je crois que je suis enceinte donc à
celle dit mais tu ne peux pas être
enceinte
non ça va pas on doit aller voir le
docteur ces donjons pour toi n'est pas
en dire ok d'accord on va dormir ce soir
de l'on va voir le docteur pour faire
l'avortement
cette soirée là pas moins eu un rêve
mais dans son lève il y avait un jeune
homme courageux barrage à ses côtés elle
comprenait pas à qui était cet homme
maman était au marché en train d'acheter
à manger et pendant que les acheter à
manger elle se rendit compte qu'il avait
acheté beaucoup disent beaucoup de
beaucoup de provisions
elle ne pouvait pas porter ça tout seul
elle avait donc besoin d'être et ce
jeune homme fort la prochain et ibo jour
maman j'ai besoin d'aidé je peux t'aider
j'ai choisi mon fils aide moi jeune
homme pris les sachets ils montrent
comment ça a marché avec ma mère pendant
qu'il marchait il dit à maman
si tu es fatigué tu peux tu peux tenir
mon bras il marchait avec moi il marcher
ensemble
arrivé à la maison maman dis merci
infiniment tu peux poser les petits
sachets sur le sur la table il posa les
sachets sur la table et il dit merci je
dois partir et ma mère lui dit mon
garçon les parents doivent vraiment être
heureux de t'avoir mais avant de partir
dix mois quel étonnant
le jeune homme regardant ai dit mon nom
et sa taille
zachary la sesat 1 sakaris et moi le
monde m'appelle zac amant regarda son
mari et 10 mois gaza réveille-toi
je ne ferai plus d'avortements mon fils
c'est un garçon je sais il s'abat et son
nom les appareils
en partie mais non tu es folle ça va pas
ça va pas le docteur a dit que tu me
faire ça ma mère dit m'y attends mais le
docteur a dit que je peux pas tomber
enceinte mais je suis ans est donc le dr
ado en tout cas si vous voulez que je
beurre j'aimerais avec mon enfant elle
refusa de faire cet avortement
sept mois plus tard j'étais n'est tout
noir
et quand je dis noir ça veut dire noir
dans le sens où j'étais vraiment noire
n'était pas j'étais pas la couleur
naturelle d'un bébé j'étais pie noir
vilain et je criais
je suis venu sur terre en me battant
j'ai réclamé ma place sur terre avant
moi y avait un enfant mais cet enfant ne
pouvait pas être parce qu'il fallait que
je vienne jeunesse était agréable dans
une famille ok nous n'étions pas riches
mon père n'avait jamais été riche mais
nous avions le minimum la lecture les
études mon père c'était l'école où je
quitte ma maison c'est l'école outil qui
peut à maison et on a eu une jeunesse
très agréable aux frères hamoir gaby qui
a trois ans de plus de plus que moi
trois ans de plus que moi avait vraiment
l'habitude de me perturber
on se prenait beaucoup la tête et un
moment donné je me souviens un jour mes
amis venaient à la maison pour regarder
un film avec moi alors gaby oh gaby est
le genre de personne maman donnerait à
chacun un verre de lait y prendrait son
verre de lait et voudrais m'en vais
redonner sa part était toujours en
bagarre
ce jour là ont regardé un film
intéressant entre copains dhabi veut
enfin je ne sais pas où il était arrivé
à la maison on est excité en attente de
regarder notre film il vient il pour la
télécommande et change de chaîne il dit
vous regardez des choses inutiles ça
c'est plus intéressant et c'était quoi
mais en train de
mais attends au méga lycéens pas
pourquoi tu m'embarrasse devant mes amis
il me pousse qu'est ce que tu vas faire
que peuvent bien faire
ils étaient plus âgés plus fort alors je
partage mon père en criant pas page dans
les mains je ne peux plus je ne peux
plus je ne peux plus mon père me dit je
suis fatigué de vos histoires à qu est
ce que tu peux pas aller faire jouer au
football va faire de la boxe il savait
pas ce qu'il avait dit mais il avait ces
mets une séance en moi ce jour là ce
même jour je partais chercher un club de
boxe
l'objectif n'était pas de battre mon
frère l'objectif était de l'intimider
j'espérais qu'à un moment donné il
serait intimider et effectivement un an
plus tard il arrêtait de m'intimider
enfin c'était un petit toi tu blagues
avec moi un situe blanca la monnaie de
leucémie qui sort pourtant avant c'était
demandez pas y sauter sur moi mais en ce
moment là c'était toi tu penses que tu
as boxeur tu penses que ça marche
c'était mon objectif principal mais
comme vous le savez je suis issu d'un
pays qui avaient des difficultés à
l'époque la guerre et tout le bazar
j'ai grandi ainsi dans le monde du sport
mais je me suis musclé l'esprit et le
corps et à un moment donné on m'a arrêté
à maintes reprise voulant que j'adhère
aux forces armées
reibel pour faire des choses incroyables
que j'estime et sa complète complètement
incohérent et puisque j'avais hérité de
ma mère sa façon de s'exprimer je disait
ouvertement je ne suis pas intéressé à
faire votre histoire
alors je devenais peu à peu comme un
résistant
alors ça devenait dangereux pour moi en
ce moment là mes parents décidé de
m'envoyer en europe
espérant me donner une opportunité
d'études
comme beaucoup de jeunes africains
d'ailleurs mais à l'époque on ne pouvait
pas y aller parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
les ambassades étaient presque toutes
fermées alors il fallait aller quelque
part ailleurs pour chercher un visa
schengen pour progresser en europe en
france et précisément alors je me
retrouvais dans un pays étranger
anglophones en attente d'un visa
j'avais quitté mon pays
j'ai rêvé de mon avenir en france dans
les rues de champs elysées j'étais
coincé dans un pays à froid anglophone
et je me souviens une soirée pendant que
je marchais je rentre à la maison de
personnes surgir dans le noir avec des
baïonnettes
j'étais tout seul et je savais qu'il
fallait jamais résisté j'avais mon
portefeuille et mon passeport
vous savez qu est ce qu ils ont pris mon
passeport
oui le seul passeport avec lequel je
pouvais avoir un visa pour aller en
europe était pris je pouvais donc plus
aller en europe à cause j'ai commencé à
pleurer mais mon dieu pourquoi pourquoi
c'est un mois que ça arrive
qu'est ce que je veux faire je veux pas
rester ici j'ai commencé à pleurer mais
je ne comprenais pas que c'était une
ouverture à autre chose
j'étais coincé dans un pays tout seul à
la merci de la vie ne sachant pas où
aller
que faire je faisais des boulot
incroyable j'ai lavé des voitures
j'ai surveillé des voitures j'ai été à
maintes reprises insulter par des
personnes qui ne valait pas pas plus que
moi parce que je faisais des boulot
incroyable incroyable à l'époque mais je
ne savais pas que j'étais forget ils
étaient en train d'être forget à devenir
une personne différente une personne d'
influence une personne qui laissent des
marques et les choses mauvaises terrible
ou douloureuses qui nous arrive nous
arrive pas toujours pour les mauvais
exemples dans ce pays là c'est là où
j'ai commencé la boxe
professionnellement parce que je n'avais
pas d'autre issue
c'était la seule façon de pouvoir
survivre et pouvoir payer à manger mon
père m'a envoyé 200 dollars à la fin de
chaque mois mais que peut-on bien faire
avec 200 dollars dans un pays étranger
pas grand chose mais à un moment donné
j'ai dit à mon père papa je ne veux plus
que tu m'envoies de l'argent je suis
assez grand à me battre et je me battais
mais je savais nous vivions dans une
maison de deux chambres à 25
tout ce jeune était ambitieux courage
vous le voulez se retrouver dans la
ville voulait faire quelque chose de
positif
mais je savais où je devais m ce n'était
pas là je voulais une vie différente
malgré les difficultés auxquelles j'ai
été confrontée
je savais qu'ils avaient déçu tout le
monde est venu mais personne ne naît
démunis nous avons chacun une chose
quelque chose de spécial quelque part
une chose qui ne s'est pas du tout le
monde j'étais plus fort quand j'étais
plus jeune j'étais vide est presque tous
mes amis de l'école mais qui peut bien
faire de l'argent ou vivre de sa force
si je me disais à l'époque
avez vous déjà vu un diamant à l'état
brut
il n'a pas l'éclat d'un diamant que vous
connaissez j'étais un diamant à l'état
brut
mais le temps les difficultés et les
souffrances les refaire de la vie ont
nettoyé lustré ce diamant que j'étais je
suis devenu champion intercontinental de
boxe sans expérience amateurs beaucoup
font sans combat 200 combats amateurs
avant de devenir professionnel et en
toute l'expérience possible je n'ai
jamais connu ce monde je suis entrée
dans le monde professionnel et j'ai
commencé à bombarder ces professionnels
je connaissais la direction je savais ce
que je voulais je bossais plus dur que
tout le monde
champion intercontinental 1 battue je
suis parti en europe si bien vos
contrats on me disait que le contrat est
prêt mais nous voulons que tu rentres
faire un combat après ce combat du cnra
le gros contrat kelly a pâti aussi qui
peut me battre je suis rentré mais ce
moment là j'avais complètement négligé
les choses qui m'avait millas à cette
place de chose qui m'avait bâti
l'entraînement la sérieuse it et parce
que l'argent coulait à flot comme un
jeune homme de 24 ans à l'époque je
faisais comme tout le monde je voulais
faire comme tout le monde je voulais
aller m'amuser je voulais aller en boîte
je voulais avoir en tout au moins des
jolies fleurs et bien c'était justement
là que je commençait à tomber mon
adversaire était un gars avec un gros
ventre dont vous savez nous avons
tendance à penser que pour être fort il
faudra développer
je me savais en province je les aimais
ses gardes
ça c'est de l'argent facile en bleu mais
je ne savais pas que c'était le moment
qu'ils changeraient ma vie aussi le
monsieur avait rossé comme jamais et
c'était de l'est sont de riz le contrat
en europe
au revoir j'ai traversé a montré ce
moment là c'est là que j'ai compris que
cette situation que tu rencontres dans
la vie est une porte ouverte à une
nouvelle réalité peu importe ce que
c'est que ça soit la douleur la peine
vous avez perdu quelque chose le moyen
principal de votre revenu vous quitte la
personne principal de votre ville dit
est une porte ouverte à une nouvelle
réalité
la vie m'a donné une nouvelle chance
comme vous l'avez vu je suis allé dans
un terrain complètement étranger aux
devenir sion pur du monde encore une
fois chose qui n'avait encore jamais été
réalisé par une personne champion de
boxe jean paul de type boxer de
discipline totalement différente
c'est l'esprit digère tout c'est
l'esprit qui décide où tu as 35 ans plus
tard je regarde
qu'est ce que je réalise cette dame
cette maman si elle n'avait jamais connu
cet accident de voiture je ne serai
jamais entendu parler je n'aurais pas
inspiré autant de personnes je n'avais
pas apporté cette positivité que
j'inspire travers le monde aujourd'hui
35 ans plus tard zach moins qu'à ça en
plus d'être boxeur professionnel
champion de boxe et le type bac 5
ingénieur de réseau écrivain entraîneur
influenceurs
n'est ce pas une porte ouverte à une
nouvelle réalité une réalité qui était
destiné d'être une réalité de tristesse
mais une réalité car totalement changé
aujourd'hui je voudrais célébrer ma mère
cette femme autrefois handicapés parce
qu'elle lui qui à travers la douleur
qu'elle a connu j'ai pu connaître cette
terre mon nom exact - qu'à ça le
guerrier noir mat
[Applaudissements]